hi everyone my name is Chandra chambers
and this is Tara's never seen today I am
watching Escape from New York I am so
excited to watch this movie because I
have a newfound love for Kurt Russell
and a newfound love for John Carpenter
just in case anyone missed it I said
that I wasn't a huge fan of Caressa Lynn
the thing reaction video and that's
because I am a liar
Magi giant liar I was getting Kurt
Russell and Jeff Bridges confused Jeff
Bridges just isn't my favorite he
doesn't really do it for me I think he
was great as the dude um he just kind of
bugs me and like virtually everything
else I just tweeted out send me those
Escape from New York predictions now
hashtag cameras ever seen Statue of
Liberty emoji fire emoji you haven't
seen the premise of this film is so cool
it's got like a pervy vibe to it I know
that this obviously came way before it's
super creepy and scary and kind of like
I don't know Mad Max II in a way like
the original ones and and everyone says
not to watch the second but I'm
definitely going to watch the second I
should have a second month I think it's
like I should watch the second mask I
should watch the second escape from new
york which is escape from LA
first thing i wrote is oh no kirti no
first of all where did your I go second
of all why are you going in what did you
do no they are giving him a life in New
York which is a life of no escape New
York has turned into this crazy giant
jail and that's horrifying that's
horrifying
movie starts off on this renegade pilot
flying Air Force One into New York she
wants to kill the president first
encounter with this guy in New York in
the scary prison state and he's giving
them their terms on what he wants them
to do and how to save the president and
he kind of looks like the guy from death
so that good enough that's fine
I ordered all three Death Note movies
but it hasn't come in time so sorry
you're stuck with it so they offer Kurt
Russell a full pass he doesn't have to
go to this crazy New York Jail
state any longer if he goes in there got
22 hours and he saves the president
snake is fucking awesome some of the
dialogue that he has is actually just
incredible and it all happens at the
very beginning he's got like 30 lives in
the whole film and all of them aren't
like this badass Whisperer level where
you're like there's a lot of explosions
and shit happening in the background
how's anyone hearing anything this guy
says oh my god so cool I'm gonna use
this now that like I don't give a fuck
right now like no sad snake doesn't take
snacks snack I meant to say that this is
an assassin ache we're talking about
I don't slither around Safin it up
everyone I've got guns and I've got
muscles all right that's what I need on
a t-shirt
snake snake pills Pilsen push Pilsen
listen snake oh god where's my last name
pitch Plissken Snake Plissken
I've got guns and I've got muscles while
to get there but that's when you know so
he agrees all their terms and they drop
him into New York to save the president
once you're in there you're on your own
you mean I can't count on you no good
he's expecting to see like this crazy
death show of people eating each other
and nutso things happening knives and
explosions and the first thing that he
captures is all these men doing a
musical upstage I love that I love it
and there's all these people the
audience just like Bob and the lung very
interesting to see what humans will do
when given complete freedom I know there
can in this confinement but like no one
cares what these guys do like you have
at it like you what you're going to do
to each other
they put up a miracle I love and I hate
humans at the same time this is an
instance of love I know what this is
reference to but it says his pants are
so tight he's got great muscles so he's
out looking for the president and the
crazies are after him and the craziest
of the people who live in the subway
undergrounds and honestly I was just in
New York the crazies are still the
people who take the subway and are
underground the cheap joke I take public
transportation the cabby picks him up
and I obviously love him I obviously
love the cabbie he's so optimistic and
nice so you find out that Duke who is
the leader of everyone in New York has
the president and they are going to the
brain who is somebody who can help them
get to the Duke lots of exposition there
you go
you're introduced to the brain and to
Maggie who I definitely want to cosplay
at some point
holy hell above she's got this awesome
like grapes colored wispy gipsy skirt
and an awesome corset and and like this
crazy dated jacket and like a gut and
eighties hair oh I said oh my god I want
to cosplay his purple dress Amy's hair
boom woman and I found out what her
actual name is Maggie
but both super very cool The Dukes cars
are hilarious he's got all these
chandeliers like mounted in his car
awesome snake gets the president in his
possession after after throwing a knife
in this guy's head and the guy like
immediately goes into slow motion nice
and then the guy just goes
like it's a get really log seeing bird
just fall buddy we get it Duke realizes
that all this is happening and he goes
and takes the president back and he gets
snake and he makes snake fight this
giant baby man and they're like oh we're
gonna chop his head off and add it to my
card it's like okay your car already has
a ton of chandeliers that's just gonna
be tacky but of course snake overcomes
and he kills the baby man man everyone's
chanting snake and these people are very
easily influenced and minds are easily
changed same the story goes in a way
were you like okay that make sense this
is what's gonna happen next and it does
he catches up with brain and Maggie and
they are it's like a fight to get to the
roof in time is that like 30 minutes and
the cabbie dies and brain dies and since
brain and Maggie are in love Maggie
shoots at the tacky chandelier car
president and snake get over the wall
and Duke is down there and the president
shoots Duke if he has a moment like a
like a crazy breakdown moment like a hot
second of like greatness crazy you're
number one you're the dude yeah I gather
is pretty good pretty special moments
snake delivers him with no seconds to
spare it's perfect the countdown is
amazing the whole thing is that he
needed this tape to like smooth over
peace with China or some shit and and do
curse custom Remus today gives him the
wrong tape and it's just the music of
the cabbie was playing and it's so good
and he walks away pissed off and he's
like taking the tape apart because the
president didn't care about and it was
lives it was a really cool action film
social commentary and like just great
two hours of like watching Kurt Russell
kick ass there's not many premises I
feel that haven't been seen before and I
know all of you have seen this I'm not
seeing this premise and I didn't know
what it was and I'm wondering why escape
from LA is going to be so much worse
people say it's like a parody of this
one so I
I'm definitely going to watch it because
I was all about this movie he'll
reference the fact you were just in NYC
like a week ago
yes sure did if you'll wear an eyepatch
at least was to look cute I don't know
if I was cute but I sure I sure as much
as you could look cute where you can and
you'll never look at Broadway the same
way he totally it was really cool seeing
the giant worlds that these prisoners
had created so it was really chaotic I
want to believe that if I was in this
situation and I was living in New York
as a prisoner that could never escape I
would find like a sweet-ass apartment I
would like lock it up really well I was
like hoard food and like I don't know
work my way up like I don't know I feel
like I would be pretty pretty good men
it's best that you pitch it
the cabbie will be one of your favorites
Ernest Borgnine is the man names the
cabbie was definitely one of my
favorites the cabbie and Maggie and
obviously her con god man I predict you
what chandeliers through a place for
headlights on your car oh they were head
laughing okay I thought they were fancy
Kurt Russell is still super duper sexy
now it always mam's now and always it
started and I heard the premise and I
was just like on board I am on board I
will never not be on board for this I'm
just so curious and confused to like how
the second one could be that much worse
thanks for watching everyone I will see
you next week check out my personal
channel Tamra Lynne chambers at
youtube.com I put things out there
weekly and I will see you guys next week
thank you for watching bye
[Music]
[Applause]
you